the red starting pitcher sunny gray
numbers from western and southern he's
looked different of late he has and i
think the difference that you'll see
it's very subtle but he doesn't seem to
want to overpower the hitters like he
did earlier in the year and maybe
earlier in his career backing off a
little bit his command is improved his
breaking ball is still very sharp and
boy does this basketball have a lot of
run
tommy edmond is the table setter
and tommy lifts it in the air out to
right castiano's back at the
nothing cardinals
lead off homer
tommy edmond number 10 this year
saint louis strikes first in game two
well we were just talking about the
fastball look for one of those things in
drive it well he gets one of those
things 92 it's in and doesn't get all of
it actually gets in on him a little bit
but tommy's able to strengthen the and
just put the muscle into it get it out
wow what a start how about that the
second leadoff homer for tommy edmond
this year one nothing after a half
inning jay half gets a start for st
louis the lefty is eight and six so
those are the season numbers start
number 25 but you look at what he's done
with the cardinals it's been awfully
good cassiano's has crushed and i mean
crushed j happ in his career
[Applause]
[Music]
that was an off speed pitching the
difference between the first swing that
he took on the heater
and that off speed pitch that little
pause hesitation as i said just staying
through the baseball that's what staying
through the baseball looks like you know
barry you used a turn on opening day
that i had not heard in a long time
about when you get a curveball
did you say crushed i did and he keeps
crushing hey eugenio suarez
suarez a big blast deep left center
field
leap at the wall it's gone
hey eugenio suarez sucka
a pair of two run bombs by the reds in
the opening inning
and i think they're going to check to
see if that was indeed a clean home run
it's got to hit the concrete or the
little bar behind that in order to be a
home run if so if it hits the top of the
outfield wall behind it home run but the
line itself is in play
homer off the board sending them back
to second and third now it's back to a
one-run game the base is loaded what an
opportunity just traded from the red sox
yesterday joined the team today delino
de shields 3-2 pitch
and the shields gets underneath it fly
ball into left
what was once a 4-1 game is now 2-1 reds
have loaded the bases for the second
straight inning they loaded them with
nobody out and nick castiano's who has
absolutely owned jay half coming to the
plate
drills it
left center field
gone grand slam
there's a conference on the field
amongst the umpires mike shield came out
and said something to home plate man
corey blazer who then summoned all the
umpires out of the infield grass
they want us back bill cosby is hand
motioning they want his bat david bell
is coming out to speak with phil cousy
and here comes castiano's with his bat
he's hand delivering it
here you go check it out the castillanos
has been using this batch for several
days yes he has castillanos gave that
back to a fan after hitting the grand
slam then had to get it back out of the
stands to present it to the umpires who
are now talking to new york they're
going to go for a rules
uh qualification here with new york to
find out whether if a chipped bat is
actually an illegal bat so it appears
not at a legal bat grand slam stands
just his second two homer game of the
year his second grand slam of the
campaign and jayhab really hasn't shown
anything to keep these right-handed
hitters off farmer popped to first
farmer sends one high in the air deep
right center field
bye bye baseball
the offense is back it's an 8-1 drubbing
in the second
well you can eliminate a pitch
and look for one that would be the
fastball
farmer on time and when you throw that
hard the ball elevator is going to go a
long
a long way i think everyone's eager to
get in on some big swings that'll close
the book on hat by the way adam olson of
the cardinals medical team coming out
something not right there with junior
fernandez
and now that's not good with fernandez
who spun away and then something not
right clearly with him right there he
called over to the medical team right
now junior fernandez will exit and uh
mike schilt again
going back to his bullpen we'll see the
third pitcher used here in game two it
began with half fernandez man he'll go
straight to the cardinal clubhouse
daniel ponce de leon looks to be the guy
[Music]
hot shot fair
the shield's first hit is a red aquino
giving the wave in third he storms home
they eat it outfield grass the shields
now breaks for third a fire defender
gets away
9-1 at third one out person third one
out kyle farmer's gone deep
farmer shoots this one to deep left
center
track down on the track by tyler o'neill
runners tag castello scores suarez up to
second sac fly rbi
and the reds keep pouring it on double
digits for cincinnati
that one hit to left wave is on
suarez sent home fire goes to third safe
slide in the third of aquino the shields
takes plum advantage head first slide to
the second base
arenado at the plate
the 2-2
out to left and a home run for nolan
ornato number 27.
and he's driven in 85.
he says throw it back she's saying i
don't know if i can it's a souvenir i
got it it's a nolan or an auto home run
do i do it
and at this point she has not thrown it
back yet
and that home run for nolan arenado
number 27 as a saint louis cardinal he
got himself a hanging breaking ball we
were just showing you the numbers he
likes to hit at this ballpark catches it
out in front
gives a souvenir to a fan who we believe
to this point
has kept said souvenir it's 11-2 a
bludgeoning
hey johannio suarez
his second extra base into the game
his first was rule the homer
[Applause]
and overruled after being challenged on
replay he gets all of this one
location of that pitch once again
but just put a good old swing on it geno
i think that was a statement of
check that one 12-2
cincinnati sanchez is the runner at
second two outs one and one on paul de
young
the young sent it stung to deep center
field and deshields was there once more
the reds take it by 10 as they trounce
the cardinals in the finale
they gain a game of breathing room in
the wild card chase
[Applause]
you